hello everyone in the previous video I
had discussed the importance of
developing problem solving skills and
developing language skills for school
students studying between standards 6th
and 10th in response to that video many
students had requested me to discuss
more elaborately on developing problem
solving skills so in this video I'm
going to do just that to discuss certain
topics certain tips uh which can help
you develop problem solving skills
before I get into the points i' would
just like to point out two things first
of all I am not a master Problem Solver
in fact quite the opposite of that all
throughout my life I have had to
struggle quite a bit on developing my
problem solving skills because when I
was at school I had made some terrible
terrible mistakes and I had to overcome
that so probably the things which I'm
going to discuss based on my own
firsthand experiences many of the
students currently studying in maybe
Class 7 8th 9th 10th especially if they
are in the higher standards uh they are
thinking that it's too late for them
probably they'll be able to relate to me
and this was the kinds of mistakes which
ultimately led me to not being able to
get through IJ in my first attempt
although I was uh successful in my
second attempt the second point which I
want to mention is that I am very very
enthusiastic about discussing this tips
so probably on certain points I may go
on an over enthusiastic rant so please
bear with me however I think that if you
are someone who is struggling with
developing your problem solving skills
if you uh listen to this uh extended
discussion to the very end you will get
benefited through some of the things
which I have authentically tried to
extract from my uh own experiences all
right the first and foremost thing is
that for problem solving for developing
problem solving you have to approach it
like you approach a game yes that's
right so whether it is a field game like
Cricket football or some kind of an
indoor game like badminton maybe even
chess or even a video game you know know
for a fact that you cannot cannot play
at the higher levels of the game without
first gaining a Proficiency in the lower
levels of the game take Cricket for
example in the Gully Cricket just in
front of your house if you cannot
perform well how can you go to a field
and perform well at that stage if you
cannot perform well at that stage how
can you even Harbor dreams of playing
for your school if you cannot play well
for your school how can you Harbor
dreams for going to the state level for
going to the National level so it always
like that you have to keep on leveling
yourself up and ensuring that each level
that you reach and attain is something
which you become proficient at and only
then you can uh go to the next stage so
how does that work for problem solving
if it is similar to a game well in
problem solving first of all you have to
get yourself acquainted with the routine
things the routine things means the kind
of things which are taught at school it
may sound a little bit of a boring
advice but it is true it is true so
just see if if you are if you're not
familiar with all the theorems with all
the things which are taught at school in
a very routine way how can you even hope
for going uh to more imaginative more
creative kind of problems so that's
that's the Stark truth it just doesn't
work any other way that said it is also
true that if you just keep on doing the
routine kind of things you are never
going to level up so you must pursue the
challenges in a very very active way
this is a key step towards developing
problem solving skills what do I
actually mean by that let me try to give
you an analogy so see I have been riding
bicycles all my life okay now I drive a
car but uh even after becoming a faculty
I was riding my bicycle so starting from
my college I was doing this it was very
easy for me and despite that the highest
skill that I managed to achieve was that
I could ride my bike by leaving my two
hands from The Handlebar this was the
top not skill that I developed during
all those years like 15 years 20 years
of riding bikes compared to that you
take the example of another guy who is
less than half my age and maybe he is
competing in some kind of a those X
sports kinds of things where they do all
sorts of stunts with bicycles just
imagine his level of skill and my level
of skill how did he get to achieve that
level of skill by actively pursuing
challenging things on his bicycle day in
and day out after you have done the
routine things it is incumbent upon you
it is absolutely mandatory for you if
you're really interested in developing
problem solving skills to go to the next
challenge you have to seek out that
challenge in a very active fashion there
is no other way about it okay there is
absolutely no two ways about it this is
the way you have to go about doing it
now now when we say like you have to go
for more challenges what is ex exactly
that well you have to go for more
challenging problems certainly but it
also means that for the higher level you
have to start doing some of the routine
things in a more challenging fashion in
a more non-routine way what I mean by
that is perhaps nowadays at at at at
your current level of um of skills you
are being taught the theory part by your
teacher in some very traditional way but
the next the immediately Next Level
would be to start reading the theory on
your own trying to delve deeper into
that theory trying to learn the theorems
by yourself trying to extract the
meaning of that and then attacking the
problems yourself if you can do that
then yes you are really have gained a
lot of proficiency in the traditional
routine things and you're ready for the
next next step and after that s uh
considering that you are successful in
this next step you are ready for the
next challenge that would be to tackle
higher and more challenging problems the
the the thing which you have to remember
okay so when you go for such kinds of
more difficult problems is that you have
to be patient about it this is well this
is like the Bedrock Foundation of of
your entire Journey okay this is the
like the absolute truth of your entire
journey of developing problem solving
skills that you have to be patient and
you have to let yourself not become
frustrated at the continual failures
that you are inevitably going to face
what I mean by that is that when you
face a more challenging problem you are
of course not going to be able to solve
it so what do you do well it is natural
to become frustrated but you cannot let
that bog you down so you have to take a
look at the solution but just looking at
the solution and getting to know oh yes
that is the solution and then going on
to the next challenging problem that is
not the way the way is and here I'm
telling you from my own very first
firstand experience is that uh you have
to really do a postmortem analysis of
that problem you have to completely
unearth your weakness extract the
fundamental reasons why you are not able
to do it was it because of some la of
concept was it because that you perhaps
completely forgot that you that you even
knew a certain theorem which had to be
applied here was it perhaps a lack of
identifying a connection between two
disparate Concepts so sometimes a
particular problem will involve maybe
two or three different concepts maybe
from different chapters so you have to
you have to kind of identify the link
between these uh disparate apparently
disparate Concepts so was it perhaps
this failure on your part to identify
that link that connection what was it
what was that weakness that led to your
failure in solving the problem this kind
of a postmortem analysis if you do not
do then well success will not be yours
I'm sorry to say this but this is the
truth many people they do
this okay they do this kind of
postmortem analysis after have failed to
solve the problem but what they don't do
and this this is the next important
highlight of my suggestions is that
sometimes they do manage to solve a
problem
successfully but even then a kind of um
after the fact analysis is required
meaning that it is possible that in your
journey towards developing your problem
solving skills
you develop certain ideas certain
intuitions certain U tricks maybe to
solve certain problems you start getting
some kind of bright ideas to solve
problems now when you get such a bright
idea and you are able to quickly solve a
problem please do not get satisfied by
that just like when you fail to solve a
problem you have to do an analysis for
this similarly after you have
successfully solved a problem maybe in a
very fast way
uh absolutely celebrate the fact that
you are able to do it but take a step
back backtrack a little bit and try to
une again extract for yourself what was
it that led you to successfully solving
that problem first of all try to think
of the various ways that you could have
taken which would not have led to the
solution of the problem because it might
very well be the fact that you were able
to solve the problem successfully in a
very very accidental manner which is a
happy accident but it is an accident n
nonetheless it is not something from
your deliberate intention so while it is
good that you successfully solved the
problem you have to identify what are
the steps that you could have with equal
probability taken but somehow just
accidentally you did not
take so if you are aware of those kinds
of pitfalls then and only then in
another kind of situation something
really Rel ated you will avoid making
those kinds of pitfalls I know I'm
speaking in a very abstract way but I
have I have seen myself my own younger
self do these exact same mistakes and
that is why I'm trying to tell these
things and those who have had some
amount of struggle some amount of fight
with themselves while solving problems
they will know for effect what I'm
talking about okay so a postmortem
analysis for for failures
and successes both are necessary
absolutely necessary you must also try
to find out that so it's kind of like
slowing down your thinking deliberately
so when you have a blazing thought it
sounds very exciting but then you have
to identify what was it that led to that
kind of a brilliant blazing thought try
to try if possible to slow down your
thoughts try to think what was it that
inspired that blazing thought that
brilliant uh idea maybe you read
something maybe you had done some kind
of a very similar but apparently
unrelated problem which inspired you so
when you do a problem very quickly you
don't realize what what is it that is
probing you forward but when you slow
yourself down you try to try to unearth
these kinds of apparently unknown
Connections in your brain only then you
will be able to get familiar with your
brain I don't know any other way to put
it better
but this problem solving skills
developing problem solving skills is
also very much a way of getting to know
yourself
better I I don't want to sound
unnecessarily philosophical but it is
what it is you have to you get to know
your brain better by following these
processes okay so that was about
analyzing your failures and successes
next up is beyond getting to know what
was going inside your brain what you
have to unearth and try to uh process
what could have happened with the
problem itself what I mean by that is
and I completely owe this tip to
Professor Jen Kapoor who had a crucial
role to play in the development of the
Indian
Olympiad uh environment Professor Jane
kapor was at I kpur uh so he had always
uh stressed the importance of problem
posing so just like problem solving is
important to develop problem solving you
have to develop a knack of problem
posing means developing questions from
your own when you solve a challenging
problem uh try to pose similar sorts of
questions initially the kinds of
questions that you are going to pose are
going to be very very simplistic in
nature very very simple maybe you change
the values a little bit here and there
and then you see what happens then as
you grow in maturity you will try to uh
maybe make it a little bit more
sophisticated and then a little bit more
sophisticated and that's how you grow in
your skills of actually understanding
the heart and soul of the problem so
when you make questions okay please do
not think that it is only teachers who
have the right
to make questions anybody can make
questions you as a standard six student
can also make questions there is nothing
stopping you okay who says that only
like 30 40 year old people can only make
questions you have full right to make
questions take a question make something
similar okay so when you do that the
kind of insight that you will have into
the motivations of setting up the
problem that will help you in complete
in a completely different scenario and
who knows maybe the kinds of thought
processes that you will develop in this
process of posing questions will
actually help you in uh solving
something which somebody else may be
posing to you but going through the same
kind of thought process that you are
going through now I hope you get my
drift okay another thing is that uh when
you do this kind of an exercise you have
to uh sort of appreciate some of the
more subtle Nuance things associated
with with a with a problem and its
solution what I mean by that is uh
so certain problems have certain kinds
of symmetries involved now identifying
the symmetries appreciating the
symmetries uh and symmetry need not
always be like a like an absolutely
concrete symmetry that you have in
geometrical kind of problems rather you
can have symmetries in algebraic
problems also for example those problems
which were which are like a square + b
square + C Square so whatever what
happens if you flip around the order of
those things so uh that's that's a
symmetry what happens if you break the
symmetry so you may think that okay this
is just like ridiculous I mean okay I
mean we play around with this variables
we play around with this parameters so
what but believe it or not at the higher
levels of Science and Engineering a lot
of research work actually takes place by
actually investigating these kinds of of
symmetries and these kinds of things
phenomena which happens uh on Breaking
the symmetry so please uh I mean have a
little bit of faith on what I'm trying
to say here uh and and try to do this
thing in a very active fashion another
exercise that you can do for yourself is
uh sometimes it's it's a bit fun to do
it uh suppose you are in class 7 or 8
maybe even class 9 and you are pretty
comfortable with some of lower class
things things like I mean very simple
things maybe addition multiplication of
uh simple like algebraic problems okay
something as as simple as that so those
are the kinds of things which your
absolute Juniors would be doing like
little kids in school so imagine that
you have a little brother like that or
maybe some little nephew or something
like that and then you wish to uh try to
impress this kid or make this uh I mean
have a little fun with this kid so how
do you go about posing uh a question
from those lower levels only for him so
for this I will take an example a famous
example from the life of the famous
mathematician gaus I don't know whether
this story is actually true or not but
it is often associated with um Carl Fri
uh gos so the story is like that um he
they were given a problem of adding up
all the numbers from 1 to 100 and he did
it in a matter of a few seconds the
trick that he did was to actually
arrange the
numbers I mean down below so it was like
he arranged it from 1 to 49 and then
from 51 to uh 99 so 1 + 99 is 100 2 + 98
is 100 all the way up to 49 + 51 is 100
so I mean the addition becomes much
easier so you can perhaps take a little
bit of inspiration from that and give to
your nephew a similar problem of adding
up the numbers from 1 to 10 okay so
accordingly you do 1 + 9 2 + 8 all the
way up to uh 4 + 6 and then you have
remaining 10 and 5 and that's how you
get 40 + 10 + 5 55 so there is that so
why I'm telling you this is that just
like you are having a little bit of a
fun I mean by kind of changing the order
of how Solutions are presented uh to
kids in a similar way try to think of
the kind of routine things that you are
studying now maybe in quadratic
equations maybe in linear simultaneous
equations the routine things that you
learn maybe in some geometrical problems
uh those uh problems involving triangles
and circles and quadrilaterals can you
perhaps flip them on their head and have
a little fun with them because when you
go for some kind of challenging
mathematical competitions or some kind
of later on entrance examinations this
is basically what the more experienced
people the people who are were setting
the questions they are doing okay so
just like you are having fun with that
little kid so also those senior people
are having fun for the problems that you
are doing at your high school level so
there is that uh and believe me I mean
the entire Olympia thing is
philosophically just this having fun
with the high school level algebra
geometry basically the high school level
maths of course there are certain higher
order things also uh like number Theory
but let's not get into that okay
um there is another aspect which I would
like to highlight is that as you are uh
doing more and more problems getting to
uh get becoming familiar with different
uh ranges of problems you will find that
um if you delve a little bit deeper
you'll be able to unearth uh maybe even
appreciate a certain hidden Beauty in
certain problems sometimes this beauty
may be directly apparent to you
uh visible to you uh from the Symmetry
uh this is something which I really
liked in algebra problems the kind of
very symmetrical things that used to
come around in the expressions of some
factorization problems even
but I mean it is good to appreciate all
this beauty but please do not get hung
up on this because this is another
mistake which I myself did okay trying
to find some kind of a beauty some kind
of an Elegance in each and every problem
that you attack that is probably not a
very healthy thing to do because there
will be definitely problems which will
not have any symmetry which will not
have any beauty you just have to
painstakingly do the steps
uh so you have to be uh like acclimatize
acclimatizing your brain with all sorts
of things so adaptability is extremely
important also so I have said a lot of
things uh I would like to end this video
by sharing one last very very important
tip and that is uh when you were
studying maths or something related to
maths like physics uh try to think of
your study material the kind of problem
solving that you have to go through not
just as some kind of a task or some kind
of uh the the the content matter there
as an agglomeration of some facts rather
think of them as some kind of like a
like an edifice of knowledge some kind
of a body of knowledge or even better
even better some kind of a device which
you have access to to improve yourself
to improve your brain this is extremely
important because otherwise it just
starts to look like a task like a menial
task it is not that especially when you
go into your study of geometry which is
laid out as a series of
theorems
but just try to take a step back and
appreciate that these theorems they kind
of build on one another the proofs the
construction ideas the connections they
always build on one another so is it not
such a beautiful Construction in itself
the whole this whole body of knowledge
this is such a beautiful construction
that is built on one on top of another
like an engineering structure so this
kind of a if you if you appreciate the
habit of studying maths uh geometry
things like this in this kind of a sense
where you try to develop an appreciation
for this innate construction which is
there to train you then you will try to
really really appreciate the beauty of
everything sometimes you may hear your
teacher saying things like this the
beauty of maths and all these things so
you yourself will be able to appreciate
these things so I could go on forever
talking about these things I will just
uh end on this note so uh the
fundamental philosophy of problem
solving
is is that it is a journey of
self-discovery okay you through this
problem solving you get to know your
brain and you get to build your brain so
I wish you all the very best and uh
people who are starting a bit late maybe
in their class 9 or maybe class 10 uh
please do not lose hope it can be done
uh it will take
effort it will consist of a lot of
struggles it can be done for those who
are much younger maybe in class six or
seven you are in for a great ride ahead
of you enjoy every moment of it try to
enjoy it really and I wish wish you all
the very best in this absolutely
wonderful Journey thank you very much
all the very best